[Musique]
messieurs bonjour Nous vous intervieons
vous aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube
qui s'appelle pview on aurait aimé avoir
un petit peu votre vision des choses sur
le côté finances géopolitique et
peut-être nous apporter ensuite des
préconisations hervid carmois bonjour
bonjour vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement je suis d'extraction
bancaire hein j'ai été dans la banque
pendant un
demi-siècle banque américaine patron
d'une grande banque en Angleterre banque
d'affaires et création d'entreprises
nouvelles qui est aussi une activité
financière et je reste
impliqué en ayant aidé à créer trois
entreprises une
entreprise qui est dans le courtagege
tradition une
entreprise qui est dans l'immobilier qui
avait commencé avec 200000 € et qui en a
200 millions aujourd'hui et enfin une
entreprise qui s'appelle appelle mdiam
donc je suis aussi le président
mais pas
l'actionnaire qui a qui est devenue en
15 ans la 4e affaire financière
industrielle la plus importante pour
créer des infrastructures et à côté de
ça vous avez une petite vie associative
dans les S tank vous avez
été
oui on travaille c'est évident que quand
on prend sa retraite il faut avoir une
autre activité
et notre famille a créé en
1780 une
association
qui a aujourd'hui 1000 personnes soigne
10000 personnes et nous voulons nous
avons été en Belgique en partie pour
financer un nouveau département dans
cette association un département pour
autistes qui verra le jour dans un an et
qui ne me paraît répondre à un besoin
français très important avec avec votre
votre expérience du monde financier
est-ce que vous pouvez me dresser un
petit peu le contexte de ce qui se passe
à l'heure actuelle tant aux États-Unis
que en Europe peut-être en Russie
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur les les
marchés financiers quelle est la
politique extérieure américaine sur les
marchés
financiers d'abord les marchés
financiers sont devenus
colossaux moi je suis frappé du fait
que les grandes entre entreprise
multinational ont 2000 milliards de
dollars 2 trillions de dollars en
liquidité qu'ell n'utilisent pas et si
les entreprises multinationales
n'utilisent pas leur liquidité les
entreprises financières qui ont elles
aussi d'immenses liquidités ne les
utilisent pas et donc la faible
croissance mondiale est
à comparer à l'immense ressource
financière qui existe de par le monde on
peut dire qu'il y a entre 15 et 25
trillions de dollars disponibles euh qui
euh se contentent de petits gains
d'intérêt entre 0,25 et 1,50 % euh euh
et qui ne font rien avec leur argent
Charles gaveav est-ce que ça raisonne en
vous
oui et non euh alors qui qui êtes-vous
Charles gaveave Charles Gave je suis euh
mettons un un intellectuel de la finance
c'està-dire j'ai toujours fait deux
choses j'ai euh
essayé de conseiller les gérants de
fortune sur ce qu' devrait faire de
l'argent de leurs client ça a été mon
premier métier puis ensuite il y a un
certain nombre d'entre eux qui m'ont
demandé de gérer de l'argent donc j'ai
toujours été à la limite de l'étude de
l'économie de la finance et de la
gestion de portefeuille ça a été mes mes
domaines d'activité aujourd'hui la
société que j'ai créé à Hong Kong en
80 18 à environ 900 clients dans le
monde entier tous chez gérant euh nous
sommes 70 personnes et nous sommes lu
par à peu près 12000 personnes par jour
et tous ces gens-là sont les nous avons
des clients dans 65 pays et comme la
France ne va pas bien j'ai décidé de
rentrer en France et de créer l'Institut
des libertés qui est un endroit où on
agite des idées gentiment donc les idées
que vous agitez quand quand Hervé nous
dit énormément de liquidités qui sont
pas investis ça ça vous fait raisonner
rebondir sur quoi est-ce que vous pensez
que ces entreprises qui n'
pas sont plutôt réticentes sont plutôt
prudentes sont plutôt
angoissé non c'est tout à fait
simple de quoi dispose l'entrepreneur ou
l'entreprise pour prendre des décisions
elle a besoin de prix tous les prix
viennent de deux prix les taux d'intérêt
et les taux de change de ces deux prix
découlent tous les autres prix le taux
d'intérêt c'est ce qui permet de
comparer le futur au présent et le taux
de change c'est ce qui permet de savoir
si vous produisez à à
l'extérieur ces deux prix sont manipulés
par les banques centrales qui savent
mieux que tout le monde de façon
absolument extraordinaire depuis 15 ans
donc aujourd'hui le système des prix
dans le monde entier ne veut plus rien
dire plus rien et donc si vous êtes un
chef d'entreprise vous n'avez
strictement aucune information vous êtes
informé par la Pravda de l'ancien temps
si je peux me permettre et donc vous
n'avez plus d'information je vous donne
un exemple o les taux d'intérêt négatif
que nous pratiquons en Europe quand
j'étais jeune j'ai appris que les taux
d'intérêt c'était simplement le prix
qu'on me payer parce pour l'incertitude
du futur vous savez on vous paye parce
que vous consommez pas aujourd'hui des
taux d'intérêt négatif ça veut dire que
les taux d'intérêt que le futur est plus
certain que le
présent vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ce qui est une abécilité logique totale
quand des chefs d'entreprisees sont face
à des banquiers centraux qui suivent des
politiques débiles comment voulez-vous
qu'ils utilisent leur cash à quoi et
pourquoi nous avons monsieur studenikov
qui est numéro 2 de l'ambassade de
Russie bonjour Comment bonjour je dis
bonjour comment allez-vous ça va merci
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de des des
manipulations des des banques centrales
sur les taux de
change B écoutez c'est ton problème sur
lequel travaillent
plusieurs chercheurs et plusieurs
spécialistes dans tous les dans tous les
institutions
euh financiers et d'études partout un
petit peu dans le monde je ne je ne
pense pas qu'il y a une vision commune
qu'il y a une position commune à ce
sujet euh mais si je comprends bien
euh ce
système dans le plan global
demande quelques modifications et
changement parce que les crises
financière qui a eu lieu il y a quelques
il y a quelques années ont démontré la
fragilité de ce système qui euh n'est
pas euh fiable pour euh pour les
économies mondiaux euh qui euh qui a
démontré ces faiblesses et euh je pense
que aujourd'hui peut-être euh euh nous
devons penser à
cette modification globale euh du
système actuel euh pour le rendre plus
euh efficace pour le rendre plus
sophistiqué pour le rendre plus euh
pacifié peut-être oui et
euh nous en Russie nous pensons aussi à
ce que l'existence aujourd'hui de cette
seule dévise internationale du dollar
américain euh aussi crée des des menaces
des dangers
euh fait les pays dépendants de cette
dévise universelle voilà pourquoi nous
optons
pour pour la diversification
des de ce système de devis euh nous euh
n essayons de utiliser le rouble et
yagne chinois dans notre commerce
bilatéral avec la Chine euh nous pensons
à
euh à
euh à faire la la la en quelque sorte la
la même chose dans le cadre de
l'organisation que nous avons créé il y
a quelques temps
euh notre nouvelle espace euroasiatique
avec la participation de certains pays
euh issus de l'union soviétique euh nous
croyons aussi que l'euro euh doit
devenir en vrai desves concurrente par
rapport à dollar donc voilà je pense que
il faut euh il faut penser il faut
réfléchir ensemble il faut
euh rendre il faut faire notre monde du
point deue financier euh plus pacifié
comme vous avez dit plus
euh plus solide euh et euh moins
dangereux pour les activités économiques
je vais rebondir une seconde sur R
carmois puis ensuite passer la parole
Olivier
beruer
Hervé guerre
économique qu'est-ce comment on peut
modéliser cette guerre économique qui
fait à travers les taux de
change il y
a le mot guerre veut dire conflit ouvert
il y a pas de conflit ouvert il y a un
dollar qui représente
80 % des échanges dans le monde il y a
des
liquidités astronomique au niveau des
montants en
dollars je dirais
que espérer que l'euro va croître et et
s'embellir et devenir une monnaie
beaucoup plus de référence impliquerait
que la France et l'Allemagne se mettent
d'accord sur la gestion
intégrée d'une monnaie intégrée en terme
de budget en terme de de de de de
d'abandon de
souveraineté au profit de l'Europe dans
le domaine monétaire j'y suis
considérablement favorable
mais les Français y sont opposés les
Allemands sont hésitant et et nous ne
progressons pas et qu'est-ce qui nous
fera progresser
éventuellement c'est une crise
financière on se dira on veut pas être
totalement entre les mains des
Américains qui reconnaissons-le dans la
façon dont il gèreent la monnaie et la
finance pour suivre des intérêts
américains qui ne coïncident pas
toujours avec les intérêts européens
Olivier Berruet
euh on a parlé de l'Alliance eurasienne
euh qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
sur le partenariat transatlantique et le
partenariat transpacifique
euh bah ici on est dans un mécanisme qui
est en train de bah d'essayer de
couronner un mouvement beaucoup plus
long qui a qui a une trentaine d'années
qui à la fin des années 70 rentre dans
une
hyperfanciarisation de de l'économie et
des relations et des relations
internationales par rapport à la finance
dont on dont on parlait tout à l'heure
on est on est face à un un système
financier qui à la base un rôle
fondamental de soutien de financement de
de l'économie qui a fini par prendre son
son indépendance quelque part
qui alors qu'à la base il est censé être
le cœur d'une économie et donc de donner
du sang à l'économie a décidé de devenir
autonome et de fonctionner que pour le
cœur et plus pour le reste du du corps
étant rétif à toute tentative de
contrôle ayant le pouvoir de menacer
tout le monde donc en disant les jambes
vous êtes pas gentil je vais vous couper
le sang donc filet droit et donc ce
système fonctionne essentiellement pour
lui-même et surtout il la capacité à
croître de façon démesurée
puisqueévidemment pour aller faire du du
bénéfice puisquon en est là sur le
financement de l'économie réelle bon on
en fait un peu enfin c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas
Royal années 70 quand il y avait 2 3 %
de rentabilité dans une banque c'était
déjà c'était déjà Hollywood
enfin mais dans ce ce système qui n'est
plus au service de l'économie mais qui
est finalement au service de laun forme
de spéculation enfin le système joue
avec le système quand on regarde les
échanges ou les produits dérivés 90 %
des contreparties d'une banque c'est un
autre acteur financier c'est pas une
entreprise qui aurait besoin d'une
vraiment d'une couverture et donc on est
dans un mécanisme en roue libre et et ce
système au niveau de la planète
aujourd'hui si si si on agrèche tout et
de l'ordre de 10 peut-être même 15 fois
le total du PIB mondial donc on a un
système qui est complètement déconnecté
des besoins de l'économie bon on
pourrait dire à la rigueur pourquoi pas
on pourra dire c'est du casino c'est
vrai mais après tout le casino bon c'est
pas moral mais c'est pas c'est pas
dangereux mais mais le système là n'est
pas contrôlé et prend des risques qui
sont complètement démesurés on a vu en
2008 200009 quand quand quand quand
quand le système a commencé à tanguer
que c'était très difficile de le sauver
donc les États ont dû et les banques
centrales injejectter des des des
centaines et des milliers de milliards
là-dedans sauf que rien n'a changé et
donc il continue à prendre des risques
il se dit même maintenant tiens j'ai une
assurance génial des des états et du
contribuable donc continuons allègrement
et tout ça n'est pas contrôlé et et ce
que j'ajouterai c'est que c'est que le
la difficulté c'est que ce système
finalement a pris le contrôle et des
banques centrales comme le disait
Charles tout à l'heure parce que certes
évidemment la banque centrale fait
n'importe quoi un peu partout on est
d'accord mais elle le fait pourquoi elle
fait pas juste comme ça elle fait au
service aussi de ce de ce secteur
financier et a pris le pouvoir du du
politique indirement des médias enfin on
voit qu'on est dans un système qui est
très très difficilement réformable
Charles bah écoutez le système est
difficilement réformable il est très
facilement réformable quand très
facilement
euh quand Ronald Rean a il y a eu la
crise des primes des
des savings and loans aux
États-Unis une crise assez grave il y a
eu 4000 chefs d'entreprise de savings
and lo qui ont été en
prison nous avons eu la crise financière
la plus importante de l'histoire depuis
les années 30 et aucun de ces garslà
qu'avait créé toute pièce de Corzine en
passant par ces garsl n'a été en prison
donc la question essentielle c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe exactement et là
je rejoins l'analyse d'Olivier il y a y
a un homme qui a demandé avir un petit
déjeuner avec moi il y a 3 4 ans qui
s'appelait Thomas huning qui était le
chairman de la Réserve fédérale de
Kansas City qui était voting member du
FED qui a voté h fois contre son
chairman bernan et il m'a dit sympatisé
on était deux chez Balthazar en bas à
New York il m'a dit Charles il faut que
je dise quelque chose tu m trs
depuis la fin des années Clinton il y a
une plutocratie qui a pris le contrôle
des États-Unis avec les trois grandes
banques que tout le monde connaît et
cette plutocratie gère la masse
monétaire et le système financier
américain au profit de cette plutocratie
et la grande question c'est comment
allons-nous américains récupérer notre
démocratie donc il faut pas s'imaginer
une seconde nous avons aujourd'hui une
mafia qui a pris le pouvoir c'est une
mafia qui est quasiment criminelle et
une manque que que de proche politique
mais le vous soulevez quelque chose de
très intéressant c'estàd que cette
plutocratie qui finance on va dire les
les les présidentibles aux
États-Unis a mis la main aussi
surocratie directement regardez
simplement les nominés de la Banque
centrale des qui est banqu centrale dans
le monde aujourd'hui ils sont tous
passés à un moment un autre par cette
plutocratie vous parlez de l'école de
Chicago non c'est pas du tout l'école de
Chicago je dirais plutôt c'est tous les
gars tous les manquers centux sont
passés par Go sax d'accord tous il y en
a ple qui sont pas passésx monsieur
studenikov comment vous voyez les
mouvement de Goldman sax ainsi que les
agences de notation quand les agences de
notation sont amenés à noter la Russie
quant à sa stabilité financière écoutez
nous avons l'impression que ces
décisions sont trop souvent politisées
euh sont trop liés avec la situation
politique dans le monde sont trop avec
l'état des relations entre Moscou
Washington euh ben que faire c'est comme
ça le modèle
actuel économique dans le monde ces
agences effectivement ce sont des
agences respectées ce sont des agences
qui
euh qui
euh joue un rôle important du point de
vue de la création de l'image de tel tel
le pays donc euh mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire euh nous construisons notre
économie nous faisons tout ce que nous
faisons euh ça nous complique parfois la
vie mais nous sommes srains nous sommes
calmes euh la situation va changer on
jour par rapport excusez-moi vous êtes
serein vous êtes calme et vous dites la
situation va changer donc je je vous
coupe va changer parce que bah nous
sommes nousous somm nous sommes nous
sommes optimistes du point de de
l'économie russe nous avons notre planin
euh à exécuter euh voilà pourquoi oui
ces agences euh prononcent leur opinion
à l'égard de la Russie et pas uniquement
à la garde de la Russie vous savez que
toutous les pays sont concernés ben rien
à faire n trop souvent nous ne sommes
pas d'accord trop souvent nous comme je
vous ai dit déjà nous sommes persuadés
que
euh certaines décisions certaines
opinions de ces agences euh sont
politisées sont lié avec l'état actuel
euh
euh de la situation politique économique
et ne reflète
pas l'état réel de l'économie russe en
tout cas est-ce que si je complètement
si je peux me permettre est-ce que vous
voyez une conjonction entre la
perception des agences de notation et
lesgardes de la Russie le fait que dès
que les tensions avec la Russie sur des
des sujets annexes annexes tout de suite
il a des répercussions sur Swift
des répercussions aussi sur les cartes
bleues à l'étranger est-ce que vous vous
sentez encerclé aussi financièrement
parlant franchement non je ne pense pas
que nous nous sentons en cerclé en plus
person pour l'instant ne réfléchis pas
ne pense pas
à cette histoire avec Swift les cartes
bleues tout marche très bien et nous
sommes tous trop interdépendants nous
sommes tous trop liés euh l'Europe les
États-Unis la Russie le monde est global
et je pense que c'est pas seulement en
Russie qu'on pense de telle façon mais
même les Américains le comprend donc
pour l'instant nous sommes là nous
sommes pas là
euh si je comprends bien en principe en
théorie cette menace existe mais le
moment n'est pas venu et surtout
maintenant quand en principe nous sommes
en phase d'apaisement des
tension à mon avis en tout cas euh le
pic de de cette confrontation a été
passé je pense Charles
si vous voulez il y a aussi autre chose
qu'il faut dire des États-Unis qui
m'inquiète passablement dieu sais que
j'ai été un soutien des États-Unis
pendant très très longtemps et je le
suis encore c'est l'ex
l'extraterritorialisation du droit
américain les Américains ont décidé
aujourd'hui qu'il pouvaient appliquer
leur droit en dehors de chez eux ce qui
est une perte de souveraineté
inimaginable pour les autres pays on l'a
très bien vu dans l'affaire de à la BNP
qui à partir du moment si vous voulez la
façon dont ça se passait dans le temps
c'est l'arbitrage c'est ça h l'arbitrage
à l'américaine ben c'est pas l'arbitrage
si vous voulez c'est que d'un seul coup
les Américains ont décidé que ils
pouvait juger un individu extérieur qui
servait du dollar parce que c'était
américain ou une société alors même que
ce dollar était réparti à deux personnes
qui n'étaient pas aux États-Unis on a vu
des affaires qui sont passées comme ça
la BNP a ramassé une énorme claque là
sur ce coup-là et alors que c'était tout
à fait inattendu donc d'un seul coup ils
ont décidé que puisque le dollar était
américain toute transaction qui avait à
faire avec le dollar était
automatiquement justiciable aux
États-Unis ce qui est un abus de pouvoir
et qui à terme met en danger le rôle du
dollar
oui c'est une remarque
essentielle je suis membre du conseil
d'administration d'une affaire qui est
la 4e dans le monde dans le dans le
domaine financier
et nous
avons travaillé
avec un client qui a été malhonnête bon
on a sanctionné on a renvoyé le client
on a renvoyé les directeurs et
maintenant la Federal Reserve et le
Trésor
américains nous impose des choix de
contrepartie en Europe et aux États-Unis
au prétexte que il y a 5 ans nous
avons eu
une erreur qui a été faite dans nos
bureaux il y a 5 ans hein bon donc les
Américains exerce un pouvoir énorme car
il nous dit si vous ne le faites pas
vous serez interdit du dollar or si vous
êtes interdit du dollarermer vous pouvez
fermer donc il y a un pouvoir américain
exorbitant
exorbitant il est ce qu'il est et je ne
vois pas que ni l'Europe ni ni le Japon
ni la Russie ni la Chine puisse dans un
délai de 10 à 15 ans contrecarré ce
pouvoir là donc je crois qu'il faut
commencer par par ça la deuxème raison
qui me paraît c'est que la masse
d'argent
disponible qui ne s'investit pas crée
des possibilités pour tout le monde
et la nous ne savons pas contrôler cette
masse bon et la troisème et je
terminerai là c'est que pourquoi est-ce
que nous ne savons pas la contrôler
parce qu'il y a
des il y a des systèmes informatiques
d'une très rare complexité que les
banques centrales appréhendent avec
difficulté que les patrons de banque
soupsonn d'exister mais ne comprennent
pas énormément et qui gè ses flux d'une
façon que personne ou très peu de
personnes ne les contrôle la masse la
complexité des flux le souci de gagner
de l'argent crée un ensemble qui à mon
avis est préoccupant Olivier ber on a vu
la masse maintenant on va on va essayer
de voir la réalité des choses comment ça
pe réagir peut-être avant sur point
parce que je serais plus je serais plus
mesuré pourant étant habituellement
assez critique des
États-Unis sur ce ce point-l
euh d'un côté moi je vais pas trop me
plaindre du fait que les États-Unis sont
peut-être le seul pays qui de temps en
temps sanctionnne des banques et qui
sont pas que des banques étrangères euh
dans l'affaire de l'énorme amende BNP
pariba faut quand même se rappeler que
la filiale à Genève de de pariba a servi
c'est de ce sont les les termes du du
procureur américain de rôle de banque
centrale du régime génocidaire du Soudan
c'est dire qu'au Soudan quand il coupait
les gens à la machette les machettes il
les a achetai grâce à Paribas Genève
donc là première question c'est pourquoi
la France a pas mis une amende à BNP
paribba déjà ce serait intéressant
deuxième point
l'extraterritorialité je vois pas trop
d'extr d'extraterritorialité là
là-dedans les transactions se font avec
du dollar le dollar au bout d'un moment
il finit par être compensé aux
États-Unis donc il disent vous utilisez
notre monnaie vous euh respectez nos
lois on peut juger que c'est que c'est
que c'est intrusif comme vous le dites
c'est assez stupide quand on a le rôle
de de de fournisseur de la monnaie
internationale mais si on est pas
content vous utilisez plus le dollar
autre chose hein c'est pas ce qui manque
sur la planète les les Mones c'est pas
ce qu'il dit si je peux me permettre ils
disent si vous ne faites pas ce qu'on
vous dit si on vous les ordrre qu'on
vous donne vous êtes interdit de dollar
c'est-à-dire qu'à ce moment-là vous êtes
punis ils ne vous disent pas vous avez
le choix vous n'avez pas le choix
puisque aujourd'hui 80 % tout le tout ce
qui s'est passé après la 2uxème guerre
mondiale c'est que les États-Unis ont
fourni le dollar comme une monnaie
internationale et l'arrangement qui
existait à l'époque qui était très
simple était de dire la Banque centrale
du pays en question d'un pays par
exemple la France vérifie que les
transactions qui ont lieu en dollar
entre deux de ces entités entre la
France et le Soudan entre la France est
conforme à la loi française et dans la
mesure où elle est conforme à la loi
française nous n'avons rien à dire ils
ont fait un reversement de charge de la
preuve totale il y a à peu près 7 ou 8
ans il y a 7 ans et ça a complètement
transformé le monde donc on ne me dise
pas ils ont tout changé qu'on ne me dise
pas que c'était comme ça avant ça
n'était pas comme ça avant aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve c'est que
les chinois sont en train de monter un
truc avec une une carte de crédit toutes
les cartes de crédit à l'arrivée sont
soldées aux États-Unis puisquelles sont
toutes américaines bah maintenant vous
pouvez avoir une carte de crédit qui est
soldée en Chine rimbi mais avant vous ne
l'aviez pas donc ils ont la ils ont
favorisé une position de monopole et
l'ayant favorisé ensuite ils
l'exploitent à leur profit c'est ce que
j'appelle du banditisme oui oui mais ça
ça vous êtes au cœur de la critique
libérale du monopole dans quelle rigueur
donc vu leur attitude stupide il y a de
moins en de monopole tant mieux oui non
mais ça prendant 40 ans hein ah en
attendant vous vous retrouvez en prison
ça peut prendre ah oui si retou en
prison vous allez utiliser de l'euro ou
du Yan non alors que vous n'avez rien
fait d'illégal dans votre pays je
m'insurge contre le fait que si je fais
quelque chose d'illégal alors que je
suis français et que je suis en France
et que les États me mettre en prison à
cause d'une loi américaine je considère
que c'est un abus de pouvoir mais
pourquoi utilisez-vous la monnaie
américaine utilisez autre chose mais
parce que j'ai c'est le même principe
que n'utilisez pas Google on n pas le
choix
% pas ch non non l' pourquoi notre
pétrole on l'achète pas en euro non mais
l'idée est assez simple c'est qu' après
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale les
Américains m'ont dit utiliser le dollar
nous ne ferons pas ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire en ce moment nous vous le
garantissons et ils ont changé d'avis
donc si vous voulez c'est un changement
de droit commercial qui s'est produit à
mon déétriment oui et ben je vais il est
évident que je vais prendre des mesures
à contre ça mais ça veut pas dire pour
une seconde que je l'approuve quand
quelqu'un quand quelqu'un change ne
tient pas sa parole je ne fais plus
d'affaire avec lui mais ça me prend du
temps mais j'entends bien vous êtes
libéré vous êtes en train de nous dire
en 45 les États-Unis ont dit filez-moi
le monopole de la monnaie faites-moi
confiance tout va bien se passer et
c'est étonnant avec la gestion du
monopole il ils usent ils abusent de ce
droit vous savez que ce qui se passe
systématiquement quand il y a un
monopole au bout d'un moment donc on
peut pas s'en étonner bah tant mieux il
faut qu'il y ait moins de monopole et la
question c'est comment on fait pour
qu'il y ait moins de monopole comm j'ai
rien j'ai rien contre ça bien sûr faut
qu'on arrive à avoir un système
monétaire international qui soit
différent qui soit beaucoup plus
équilibré on voit que les États-Unis
s'opposeront dramatiquement à toute
évolution mais on voit que par ailleurs
ils ont des attitudes de plus en plus
suprémaciste et stupide enfin en terme
de enfin quand on a la monnaie de
réserve internationale c'est stupide de
faire ça bon ben ça va pousser à trouver
des solutions alternatives qui sont en
train d'être poussé par la Chine ou la
Russie actuellement quand on a créé
internet c'est quand même un sacré
avantage d'avoir créé ça on est le
leader qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils
aspionent toute la planète donc
maintenant il y a plus un chinois il y a
plus un Russe qui achète du matériel
américain en se disant attendez c'est
branché directement sur la NSA c'est
stupide donc on voit bien que si la se
chose intéressante dans ce raisonnement
c'est si vous voulez c'est c'est penser
que les fonctionnaires à la NSA sont
compétents moi vous savez ce que j'aime
toujours avec les Anglais c'est qu'ils
ont le chance de l'humour et ils disent
toujours on paye les fonctionnaires
beaucoup trop mais au moins on en a pas
pour notre argent ce qu' veut dire par
là c'est comme ils sont incompétents
c'est c'est une très bonne nouvelle donc
s imaginez que les gars de la CIA sont
capables de suivre les information qu'il
reçoivent ça me fait plutôt rigoler
parce que j'ai persuadé le contraire
mais après après après ils vont
peut-être passer à l'intelligence
artificielle pour traiter toutes ces
tous ces c'est métat donné
l'intelligence artificielle c'est ce qui
marche dans les marchés financiers et ça
vous fait craque sur craque alors l'INT
tous les marchés financiers les
algorithmes et tout c'est que de
l'intelligence artificielle et ça marche
pas du tout ça remplace pas ce que vous
avez entre les deux oreilles hein on
pourra en reparler sur une autre
émission vous avez parlé de Snowden on
va on va entamer la partie un peu plus
géopolitique je vais m'adresser
directement à Monsieur studenikov euh
déjà merci pour l'asile auprès de snowon
en
Russie quand quand nous avons vu snowon
prendre ses quartiers à Moscou ça nous a
fait un petit peu penser à à une
revanche sur l'affaire horlof euh
j'avais la l'habitude d'en discuter avec
Jacques andrani qui était un de mes amis
et c'était notre grand sujet en disant
voilà les rus son
snowon c'est l'équivalent d'un d'un
Vladimir
Vetrov 40 ans plus tard 50 ans plus tard
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que quand vous avez reçu
Snowden à Moscou ça vous a pensé ça vous
a fait vous aussi penser à l'affaire
farwell écoutez snowon c'est plutôt euh
pour nous ce qu' a fait
Snowden c'est un acte dans citoyen c'est
un acte d'un homme qui reste patriote
qui veut tout simplement changer ce
qu'il n'aime pas dans son pays et euh
c'est un Act courageux c'est un une
personne qui vraiment que nous ne
pourrons que respecter parce que
vraiment c'est c'est un acte courageux
et a il a marché contre le système et
c'est toujours très très compliqué euh
nous nous le connaissons parce que
l'époque soviétique il y avait des gens
qui
même à cette époque là avait le courage
de protester de d'aller contre le
système ils sont ils ne sont pas si
nombreux que ça mais en même temps ils
sont nombreux donc aux États-Unis c'est
un cas un petit peu c'est c'est c'est
une histoire pas très ordinaire euh
cette histoire a provoqué un très grand
intérêt en Russie a et finalement
c'était la décision de de Snowden on n'
pas organisé l'évacuation ou pas c'est
pas une histoire deion d'espionnage il a
fait son choix il est arrivé à Moscou on
a beaucoup réfléchi on a euh vraiment on
a beaucoup étudié le sujet finalement
euh on lui a donné l'asile c'est un
homme tout à fait libre il peut faire
ses choix il peut partir quand il veut
mais nous pensons que c'était une bonne
décision de lui donner l'asile de lui
donner la possibilité de vivre de
travailler en Russie euh parce que il a
euh il a fait ce qu'il a pensé
euh juste et correct mais évidemment les
Américains ont une vision tout à fait
différente euh c'est à peu près la même
que la vôtre du temps oui oui c'est
c'est toujours c'est toujours comme ça
oui euh mais euh euh vous savez
euh Snowden il n'a rien reçu pour son
acte il n'était pas ce nit pas un agent
de quelconque service secrè c'était
vraiment sa
décision c'était sa vision des choses et
qui était sensiblement la même qui était
sensiblement la même que farwell à
l'époque farwell tu vois Vladimir Vetrov
avait trahi parce que à son
sens le KGB était une institution
complètement corrompue qui ne servait
plus l'ègle à de tête il avait décidé de
faire fuiter ce que le KGB savait en
fonction de ça Snowden a fait
sensiblement la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'il a vu que la la Constitution
américaine était foulée au pied de la
façon la plus simple possible et il a
décidé de faire fuer et de se réfugier
chez vous parce que vous étiez les seuls
à pouvoir faire bouclier contre le les
seres de l'aigle américain dans le monde
c'estàdire que même julien hassange lui
a déconseillé d'aller se réfugier en
Amérique du Sud avec tout le passé on
connaitt des Américains en Amérique du
Sud maintenant maintenant vous avez
votre président Vladimir Poutine qui a
été annoncé comme l'homme le plus
puissant du monde par Forbes euh vous
vous retrouvez pour la troisème fois
consécutif la consé quel effet ça fait
comment d'avoir son patron qui est quand
même l'homme le plus puissant du monde
écoutez ce n'est que l'opinion de de
cette magazine les autres magazines peut
peuvent avoir une autre opinion mais
cela reflète quand même quelque chose on
a Vladimir Poutine qui est amené on
passe à la partie géopolitique on est on
est Vladimir Poutine qui a envoyé des
troupes en Syrie pour pacifier ou du
moins stabiliser le cancer islamique sur
place
euh comment vous voyez l'évolution des
choses euh tout d'abord
euh nous avons beaucoupvré pour que le
processus de paix en série soit entamé
commence on a beaucoup uvrit pour que la
conférence en Genève cette petite cette
première réunion à
Genève aboutisse à la prise des
décisions concrètes pour mettre la fin
aux hostilités mais on n' pas reçu la
bonne réaction de de la part de nos
partenaires occidentaux parce que euh
ils sont toujours ou plutôt maintenant
il y a une certaine évolution dans les
approches des nos partenaires
occidentaux à l'égard de de la situation
en Syrie mais à l'époque
tout le monde était absolument sûr qu'il
faut chasser Bachar Assad du pouvoir et
après ça sera la victoire des forces
démocratiques et la vie va s'améliorer
de façon spectaculaire en Syrie donc il
faut d'abord chasser Assad du pouvoir on
était vraiment beaucoup plus prudent
déjà à l'époque tout en comprenant que
la position armée n'est pas homogène
qu'il y a un élément très important en
élément islamiste en élément radical
dans cette opposition très important et
maintenant nous voyons que euh vers
euh
l'été
2015 l'État islamique est devenu en vrai
fléo en vrai défi non seulement régional
mais global euh ils ont commencé euh en
Irak et c'est en surpris total pour tout
le monde ils ont envahi une grande
partie de l'Irak une situation tout à
fait inattendue tout d'abord par les
Américains sans parler du gouvernement
irakien donc après vous parlez de
situation inattendue ça me fait penser
aux déclarations du général Wesley Clark
concernant la déstabilisation de la
ceinture méditranéenne c'est une vidéo
qui est très très facilement accessible
sur Internet vous l'avez peut-être
d'ailleurs vu non non le général Wesley
Clark que vous voyez vous appréendez à
peu près le personnage oui bien sûron
militaireradé très connu ou qui qui
annonce euh sur une chaîne internet que
il passait par hasard au Pentagone et
qu' un de ses collègues un ancien
collaborateur lui dit venez venez mon
général j'ai un mémo classé secret à
vous montrer ce qui dépint une
déstabilisation dans la région euh vous
vous ne voyez pas de corrélation entre
l'effondrement de l'Égypte de la Syrie
de la Libye bientôt peut-être le Liban
et et le fait d'allumer un contrefeu on
va dire de business en Afrique
c'est-à-dire éviter que l'Europe puisse
se projeter par l'épendage d'un fléo ou
la la stimulation d'un fléo sur des
principes économiques vous vous avez
quelle perception sur ces fameuse
révolution de jasmin c'est ces
révolutions arabes et ensuite on passera
la parole à Hervé de carmois et à
Olivier beruer votre perception sur les
révolution arabe vous voyez pas du tout
de corrélation avec la Syrie c'est pas
du tout la même chose il y a pas très
franchement moi je pense que on peut pas
monter si facilement les révolutions
dans tant de pays de du proche de moyen
auien du nord de l'Afrique je pense
queil y avait des conditions qui se sont
réunies pour que ces révolutions commen
même si vous vous rappelez peut-être
vous vous souvz peut-être que la
première révolution a commencé en
Tunisie et c'était une chose absolument
inattendue pour la France qui quand même
a des relations privilégié avec ce pays
qui connaît tout le monde là-bas qui a
des réseaux et cetera et quand même
c'était c un surpris absolu si je me
trompe pas corrigez-moi si je suis je
suis pas raison mais je pense pour
certains analystes c'était pas du tout
c'était c'était totalement anticipé pu
d'ailleurs on pour on pour en débattre
donc pour certains analystes les
révolutions arabes étent totalement
prévisibles de par l'augmentation du
coût énergétique je vous rappelle le
baril de pétrole à 14790 qui a propagé
les émeutes de la fin un peu partout
dans la région mais c'est unon sujet à
discuter peut-être quand même les
premiers événements en
Tunisie ont été accuis avec une certaine
consternation partout et surtout en
France je me souviens très bien cette
histoire avec Madame alo Marie qui a été
beaucoup critiqué pour ses contacts avec
euh le régime au pouvoir mais euh après
euh quand c'est ce mouvement euh a
commencé je pense que les forces
extérieures ont beaucoup euh participé
et surtout je pense au pays du golf qui
ont euh soutenu certaines courants dans
les différents pays euh ils ont choisi
leur euh clients si vous voulez en Libye
en Égypte en Syrie donc euh euh le début
c'était comme d'habitude le mouvement
populaire mais la continuation avec une
forte participation extra étrangère et
après avec une forte engérence étrangère
surtout en Syrie surtout en Syrie
où certains pays du monde arabe ont
soutenu de façon très concrète
euh même en fournissant les armements
donc ils ont participé activement dans
ce
conflit interne en Syrie et dans dans
dans d'autres pays euh la Russie la
Russie a observé toute cette situation
je vous rappelle que on a bien
euh soutenu en tout cas soutenu nous
n'avons pas
euh apposé notre véau à cette résolution
concernant l'imposition euh de certain
mesur le ciel fermé en Libye euh nous
n'avons pas euh apposer notre vetau en
espérant que la pression soit accordée
sur le régime de da fi euh pour le faire
négocier avec euh les Insurgents euh
partout un petit peu dans le pays mais
surtout euh dans euh l'est dans oui dans
dans l'est du pays mais au comp
finalement euh c'est toujours le
problème euh de la façon comment on peut
traiter telle ou telle résolution donc
la résolution sur la Libye était telle
que elle a été utilisée par nos
partenaires occidentaux pour frapper
pour détruire le régime les biens euh ce
qui a euh amèer à la situation que nous
constatons aujourd'hui la Libye est
déchirée vous voulez pas le même carnage
en en Syrie on vous voulez pas le même
carnage en Syrie nous nous sommes venus
déjà assez tard euh parce que le carnage
était déjà en cours mais vraiment nous
ne voulons pas euh la liquidation euh
totale de l'État en Syrie parce que le
résultat sera euh absolument désastreux
pour tout le monde voilà c'est la raison
principale de notre euh implication dans
le conflit et n'oubliez pas que euh euh
nous nous sommes venus euh NS
partcidentau et la France ont bombardé
euh les troupes de Mamar kadfi euh sans
aucune permission et résolution spéciale
de des Nations Unies on a compris que
vous soutiez on a compris que vous
souhaitiez avoir un une perception
irréprochable de la communauté
internationale sur vos frappes et que
vous annoncez d'ailleurs quand vous
frappez le territoire syrien pour éviter
qu'il y a une bombe qui se perde sur la
tête d'un Américain ou quelque chose
comme ça et d'ailleurs vous avez
spécifié que vous allez instaurer un dô
d'exclusion arérienne pendant les Russes
frappés en Syrie c'est aussi la votre
façon du MO de prévenir les gens
attention nous sommes là nous faisons
les choses correctement d'une façon
carée on a bien compris Charles gaff
très rapidement ensuite Hervé et Olivier
écoutez je crois que puisqu'on parle de
la Syrie on peut pas comprendre ce qui
se passe en Syrie si on fait pas
allusion à la guerre civile qui déchire
l'islam depuis à peu près 14 siècles
entre les chiites et les sunnites hein
donc vous avez d'un côté les sunnites
qui représentent à peu près 60 % de la
population
mais je suis moi-même né en Syrie la
Syrie c'est un pays de multiples
communautés et toutes les communautés
savent parfaitement que si les sunites
reprennent le pouvoir en Syrie elles
vont se faire massacrer les alawites en
premier les chrétiens ce qu'il en reste
il y en a pas mal quand même les
Arméniens ils sont chrétiens également
donc vous avez une espèce d'alliance
objective de toutes les minoritaires en
Syrie s'imaginez qu'aassad n'est soutenu
que que par les alawites est une idée
fausse
il est tout à fait évident que la Russie
a eu son coefficient son son contant de
problème avec les sunites qui sont venus
intervenir en tchenie il y a quelques
années ce qui avait plus ce qu' avait
assez peu plus donc nous avons des bouts
en guerre absolument extraordinaires au
au Qatar en Arabie Saoudite qui si je
peux me permettre le merdier
partout et le plus le plus rapidement on
fera tomber ces salopart le mieux on
s'emportera tous le vrai ennemi ça n'est
pas les chiites c'est les sunit c'est
eux qui foutent le terrorisme partout
oui mais c'est aussi nos principal
partenaires nos principaux partenaires
non on se fait acheter par eux c'est pas
des
partenairesier c'est pas pareil Olivier
ber Hervé à vous on se fait acheter
Hervé pourquoi nous avons ce tumulte et
ces difficultés dans cette région pour
moi il y a une raison simple c'est que
les
Américains se retirent hein pour
pourquoi les américains se retirent
parce qu'ils ont le pétrole chez eux
hein c'est déterminant dans leur
stratégie internationale ils n'ont plus
besoin de
pétrole alors à partir de là les
Américains n'ont pas été remplacés
pourquoi d'abord parce que il n'y a pas
de
politique
moyen-orientale européenne hein les
Anglais ont des points forts qu'ils
exploitent habilement
les Français ont des traditions à
auxquelles elles sont à laquelle la
France est fidèle et et et et donc nous
n'avons pas une politique européenne euh
euh très structuré vis-à-vis de ces pays
et je dirais enfin que nous n'avons pas
les moyens nous n'avons pas surplace les
réseaux les hommes la volonté euh euh
euh que les Anglais ont eu de 1810 à
1940 et ils avaient des centaines de
dirigeants dans tous ces pays qu'ils
avaient formés dans leurs universités et
qui leur donnent un pouvoir donc je
dirais que le désordres qui prévalent à
l'heure actuelle au
Moyen-Orient vont être
durables Olivier
durable ça fait 4000 ans que ça oui ça
c'est comment ça fait 4000 ans que ça
dure donc durable ça ça le sera sûrement
oui ça c'est c'est assez c'est assez
probable
euh bah je dirais on continue à voir une
forme de de liquéfaction de de l'empire
américain qui se retire certes peut-être
à cause du du pétrole qu'ils ont chez
eux mais enfin je suis pas sûr que si si
ils voulent ils arriveraient à faire
mieux on voit bien que depuis maintenant
une quinzaine d'années les États-Unis
enfin tout ce qui touche se transforme
en plomb quoi c'est quand même assez
assez assez incroyable il en ir apporter
la démocratie bon ben on a vu après
disent la Libye vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir on a vu il a dit tien la
Syrie on va peut-être aider de trois
groupes qui ont l'air sympathiques
là-bas bah pas de bol c'est alqaïda mais
c'est assez c'est assez c'est assez
gênant donc on voit qu'on a quelque
chose de de de profond je partage tout à
fait l'analyse de Charles sur les les
Gentils messenes qui qui participent à
la haute corruption de notre système
politique le le Qatar l'Arabie Saoudite
et on voit très bien que on dit
strictement rien là-dessus hein on se
précipite pour aller leur vendre des
armes évidemment là la démocratie local
là-bas c'est pas pas être un problème
enfin en Russie ça l' nous intéresser la
démocratie en Russie au Qatar ou
enarabie Saoudite beaucoup moins
pourtant il y a des choses sympathiques
qui se passent ils on B di bourreau
tiens actuellement d'ailleurs si si des
gens sont intéressés sils ont du mal au
niveau des décapitations à suivre
euh donc effectivement voilà on a une
zone de de de danger je suis quand même
très inquiet de voir
ces cette forme de puissance qui qui
vise à
l'autodestruction au niveau des des des
États-Unis qui sème qui sème la la
désolation sur sur la planète en et
partout enfin sans sans
raison en cherchant des ennuis he c'est
c'est c'est c'est difficilement
comprensible pourquoi ils envoie il y a
15 jours un bateau là juste contre une
île chinoise enfin c'est quoi le but
c'est c'est ça leur plairait que les
Chinois envoi comme ça un bateau sur les
côtes américaines enfin asse peu donc
voit quelque chose n'est pas contrôlé et
et on voit que le système n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas réformable et par si
je répondis sur ce que je disais tout à
l'heure je partage aussi la vision je
reviens rapidement sur la finance sur
sur ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure on
n'était pas désaccord avec Charles le
système financier les problèmes
diplomatiques ça peut se résoudre très
facilement il suffit d'avoir des des
hommes politique probe souous l'intérêt
général avec une volonté euh voilà donc
en théorie c'est simple et là ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'en
pratique malheureusement on ne l'a pas
on pas poser la question tiens ça fait
quoi d'avoir le le président le moins
puissant du monde parce que c'est ce
qu'on a un peu en France bah c'est quand
même un vrai problème on voit qu'on a
des hommes politiques qui sont ou dans
la main diplomatiquement des des
Américains quand c'est pas du Qatar euh
dont le souci et dont la compétence est
très faible dont leur pouvoir a été
d'ailleurs complètement aspiré par des
instances supérieures ceci ce que disait
Charles tout à l'heure il disait c'est
facile pour s'en sortir faut remettre la
démocratie en place ouais ok c'est c'est
petit en Grèce ils ont essayé pas
marcher des masses euh on voit qu'on est
face à des forces qui sont qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement puissantes
évidemment l'Union européenne dont on
dira un mot j'espère tout à l'heure a
aussi un rôle làdedans de frein
considérable euh soit c'est un frein
soit d'ailleurs ça met de de l'huile sur
le feu comme ça a été le cas en en
Ukraine donc moi en tant que citoyen
dire j'ai honte et j'ai honte en
permanence dire j'ai honte quand je vois
François Hollande se comporter comme il
le fait avec la Russie j'ai honte quand
on soutient euh un gouvernement dont il
y a quand même des des des des quasi
néonazis au au pouvoir il y a il y a il
y a un an c'est un peu moins le cas
aujourd'hui j'ai honte quand on voit euh
que d'ailleurs le François Hollande dans
un livre avoué qu'en 2012 il a fourni
des armes au aux rebelles syriens enfin
enfin déjà enfin de quoi on s'occupe euh
de deuxièmement c'était d'ailleurs
interdit par l'Union européenne he il y
avait quand même un embargo à ce
moment-là qu'on a joyeusement non
respecté en douce j'ai honte quand le
Ren faabus va nous expliquer que le
front alnostra fait du super boulot
alors même qu'on lui pose une question
sachant que ce front vient d'être mis
sur la liste des organisations
terroristes par les États-Unis 3 mois
plus tard il s'affilie à Al-Qaïda enfin
c'est quand même fabuleux c'est quand
même fabuleux je dire et en ce moment
les rebelles syriens ont des armes
françaises qui ont été généralement
fourni par no grand démocrate du Qatar
et de l'Arabie Saoudite on y revient qui
qui sème la désolation sur la planète et
voilà donc on ne fait rien on continue
d'ailleurs dans ces dans ces attitudes
suicidaires on a fait semblant de les
bombarder pendant pendant pendant C VI
plaisanterie c'est la vieille
plaisanterie si vous voulez si dans le
monde quand il y a pas il vaut mieux
avoir un gendarme fou qu'une absence de
gendarmes et aujourd'hui on est dans un
monde où il une absence de gendarmes
donc tous les petits terroristes de base
poussent sur les portes en espérant
qu'elles seront ouvertes et il n'y a
aucune résistance et donc je ne connais
pas 10 je connais bien l'histoire du
Moyen-Orient il n'y a jamais eu un moyen
tranquille s'il n'y avait pas un empire
qui imposé sa loi par la force à
l'ensemble de la région c'est-à-dire
c'était l'Empire ottoman avant ça
c'était l'Empire byzantin avant ça
c'était l'Empire romain puis les Grecs
il n'y a jamais eu une période où le le
Moyen-Orient ne soit pas mis sur la
gueule comme des fous entre eux s'il y a
pas un empire et maintenant ça va être
l'empire turc l'Empire russe j'espère
écoutez en ce qui concerne le gendarme
je pense que il y a un gendarme mais un
gendarme incapable
voilà guerre ne termine pas évacue ses
troupes et
après ils dépensent 5 % de leur PIB
chaque année après les Américains et ils
réussissent pas dès qu'il y a un homme
de tuer ils s'en vont donc si vous
voulez à quoi ça sert de déper 5% viment
regardez la carte du procheorien du
MoyenOrient ils sont entrés en Irak en
Afghanistan il participe activement dans
les affaires en Syrie il y a aussi
l'Égypte il y a la Libye partout le
chaos total pas de succès pas une seule
guerre gagnée complètement et au un
moment donné il voulait aussi bon pas
attaquer Iran mais en tout cas vraiment
on était pas au bord de la guerre
peut-être mais il y a pas mal de de
personnalités des politiciens à
Washington qui qui qui qui voulaient
vraiment frapper et non seulement
Washington et pourquoi d'où ça vient
parce que c'est quand même
extraordinaire on fait tous le même
constat c'est extraordinaire in capacité
des États-Unis mais pourquoi c'est leur
système politique est devenu fou on
parlait de du chaos contrôlé la théorie
du chaos contrôlé mais il paraît que ils
ont créé le chaos mais ils ne le contrôl
plus Hervé oh c'est
l'incapacité des États-Unis à gérer le
Moyen-Orient existe de tout temps il n'y
arrive pas il n'y arrive pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les hommes parce qu'il
voi pas la mentalité et fondamentalement
parce qu'il n'y voit plus leur intérêt
et les États-Unis sont bons hein comme
euh alors qu'est-ce qu'ils vont y
s ils ont plus d'intérêt qu'il les
laissent tranquille mais ils continuent
à intervenir comme des fous bon ils
interviennent parce que euh ils se
retirre doucement qu'il y a des conflits
de personnes au sein des des haut
dignitaires militaires américains que il
y a des conflit de d'intérêts financiers
à tous les niveaux je veux dire c'est
c'est c'est c'est cette complexité là
mais les Américains ont pris la décision
de se retirer de cette région ils se
retirent mal personne n'y va à leur
place et les Européens absolument pas et
et donc nous allons avoir du tumulte
local en
croissance comment comment pouvez-vous
dire qu'il se retire du Moyen-Orient
alors qu'il continue toujours à avoir un
soutien forcené à Israël qui est une
pièce au Moyen-Orient très bien très
bien c'est
je je je dis le Moyen-Orient dans son
ensemble à l'exception et alors là vous
avez tout à fait d'Israël ou mais c'est
c'est c'est comme un bout important du
MoyenOrient qui a des conséquen bout
important il faut dire il y a 8 millions
de Juifs aux États-Unis ou mais c'est
tout mais il faut dire que les
Israéliens aussi il a ils ont ce
sentiment que les États-Unis partent
bien sûr mais absolument ils ont aussi
le soutien existe les relations sont
très denses très privilégiées mais les
les aussi il se sentent un peu seul dans
ce is il vont s'allier au jordaniens et
aux Égyptiens toutes affair parce que
tout leur intérêt et sans oublier le
conflit
arabo palestino-israélien parce que là
ce conflit est complètement
oublié stagnation total et ça aussi ça
cré mais les les Américains
interviendront massivement si
l'existence d'Israël est menacée pour le
reste ils se retirent au mieux de ce
qu'ils peuvent alors ils ne peuvent pas
très bien
euh est-ce que l'empire
l'Impérium américain vaut en qualité ce
qui a été pendant 130 ans l'Impérium
britannique la réponse est non hein et
et pour des raisons très profondes de
disponibilité d'hommes d'intérêt pour la
région de
euh et de qualité de leur diplomatie
bon ben nous devons nous européens et
français en tirer les conséquences et se
dire que euh si nous ne prenons pas en
main notre destinée personne dans cette
régionl personne d'autre ne le fera
notre place mais pouvons-nous vraiment
le faire parce que la question la
question est là Charles disait tout à
l'heure à quoi ça sert de dépenser 5 %
du PIB dans des dépenses militaires
enfin bon nombre de parlementaires
américains ont bien compris à quoi ça
servait et pour le coup enfin en tout
cas au niveau de leur cont en banque au
niveau enfin sur ce sujet-là eenower
avait fait quand même un testament il
est parti de la Maison Blanche
extrêmement poignant sur sur l'alerte
sur le complexe militaro industriel qui
aujourd'hui est un complexe militaro
financiario bancario industriel c'est un
vrai sujet enfin a-t-on le moyens de de
le faire en théorie on peut c'est facile
en pratique et la réponse est non on n
pas les moyens qu'est-ce qui manque pour
qu'on ait ces moyens il manque trois
choses il manque une volonté politique
européenne et elle ne vient
il manque une capacité intérieure à
mobiliser les les 100000 ou 20000
européens y compris anglais parce qu'ils
ont des ressources en homme tout à fait
remarquables qui
pourrai se consacrer à à à aider à la
situation là-bas et puis il manque le
fait que notre
image dans tous ces pays nous avons été
le pays
les pays colonisateurs et donc pour
passer pour effacer 150 ans 250 ans de
colonisation où nous n'avons pas eu
toujours la main légère il va falloir
encore quelques décennies monsieur
monsieur
studenikov est-ce qu'on va vers une
troème guerre mondiale bon je ne pense
pas et c'eston tabou il faut pas même
évoquer c'est cette éventualité non il
faut pas même évoquer ce sujet non je
suis absolument convaincu que euh nous
n'avons pas de raisons pour
euh pour même évoquer
cette cette guerre euh il y a pas de il
n'y a pas de rivalité idéologique
d'autrefis il n'y a pas de de régime
tout à fait si différent euh
qu'autrefois les États-Unis et l'Union
soviétique il n'y a pas de deux camps
euh l'Est et l'Ouest
non et et tout d'abord tout simplement
je refuse de d'évoquer euh cette
éventualité euh il faut euh faire tout
le nécessaire pour euh essayer de
trouver ensemble euh les sorties de
différentes crises et différents
conflits qui existent aujourd'hui euh
nous sommes toujours malgré euh cette
aggravation des relations entre euh
l'Occident collective et la la Russie
nous avons toujours plusieurs plusieurs
domaines où nous pouvons et où nous
coopérons avec succès et l'affaire
iranienne euh est une preuve de cette
coopération efficace euh tout en euh
restant
euh sur les positions différentes à
l'égard de la crise syrienne ou de la
crise
ukrainienne nous coopérons avec les
États-Unis dans le domaine de la lutte
contre le terrorisme euh dans l'espace
dans d'autres domaines donc qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce que vous dites à votre
partenaire chinois quand la Chine
déclare nous sommes prêts à faire la
guerre aux États-Unis nous n'avons pas
peur qu'est-ce que vous leur dites aux
Chinois vous leur dites vous inquiétez
pas c nous disons du calme non euh nous
disons du
calme et non mais je pense pas
que que j'entends le conflit entre les
États-Unis et la Chine c'est une
possibilité c'est une réalité je ne
pense pas parce que là aussi écoutez
c'est difficile de trouver une autre
deux pays qui sont si interdépendants du
point de vue économique et financier
donc j'ai du mal à imaginer un vrai
conflit par
contre il y a des diversence sur la mer
euh comment c'est la sécurisation du
chap per oui tout à fait il y a des
problèmes mais n'oubliez pas que la
Chine a des problèmes avec ses voisins
c'est pas une affaire chinoam américaine
c'est plutôt un complexe de sujets des
litiges territoriaux euh entre la Chine
et certains de leur de ses voisins donc
là je pense que il y a la voir
diplomatique pour trouver
euh les solutions les compromis et je
pense que
euh la Chine avec son histoire de 4000
ans avec euh euh ça savoir avec
leur
sérénité vraiment parce que quand on
parle de l'impérialisme de
l'impérialisme chinoise parfois ce n'est
qu'on reur ce n'est qu'on
vraiment chose tout à fait inventé parce
que jamais la Chine n'était pas
impérialiste si on ne parle pas des mais
la Chine la Chine sur la sécurisation du
collier de perle ça a commencé depuis on
va dire vers 2006 on a vu les troupes
américaines sécuriser le la principale
route énergétique chinoise
que les chinois construisent des îles
des portes-avion fixes nous on appelle
ça dans notre langage
euh c'est pas étonnant après je ne peux
que me prosterner devant vous avec votre
votre discours d'apaisement très
diplomatique la réalité que nous nous
percevons sur l'augmentation qu'il y a
entre votre pays l'Union européenne la
Chine et les États-Unis c'est une
augmentation grandissante nous voyons
grandissante augmentation grandissante
les signaux faibles sont de plus en plus
clair quand on voit des avions
patrouillés à la frontière des espaces
aériens que ce soit européens ou
américains et inversement c'est une
augmentation des tensions Charles
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous voyez aussi une augmentation des
tensions certes sur le système financier
mais une augmentation des tensions sur
la la géopolitique je suis absolument
stupéfait sur cette histoire de trème
guerre mondiale elle a
commencé je voudrais simplement dire
quels sont les participants cette trè
mondiale en 19 88 j'avais écrit un long
un long article pour mes clients en
prenant l'idée des idées missionnaires
de toin be qui avait trois grandes idées
missionnaires c'était la Révolution
américaine dont le dieu était la liberté
la Révolution française dont le dieu
était l'égalité et puis les musulman
dont le dieu était la soumission vous
savez quand la Révolution française est
tombée avec l'Union soviétique les les
idées j'ai dit a un énorme trou d'idées
missionnaires et la prochaine guerre ce
sera entre les États-Unis et le monde
musulmanans parce que l'ID de soumission
et l'idée de liberté sont absolument
antinomiques le monde musulman pouvait
accepter l'idée de l'idée d'égalité avec
l'idée de soumission ça va mais l'idée
de liberté est insupportable au
musulmans de liberté individuelle donc
je dis la prochaine guerre sera entre le
monde musulman et les États-Unis elle
est en train de se produire l'Europe
n'est qu'une marche avancée et ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est simplement c'est
j'imaginais pas que les États-Unis
allaient la perdre pour moi si vous
voulez c'était évident qu'il y avait une
guerre qui aré et c'était évident que
les États-Unis allaient la gagner et
puis la guerre a commencé et les
États-Unis sont en train de la perdre et
qu'on ne me raconte pas d'histoire sur
l'Europe l'Europe est en train de la
perdre puisque grosso modo si vous
voulez nous n'avons plus aucune force
militaire à part quelques unees qui
traînent en Angleterre ou en France qui
sont des restes historiques de temps
plus glorieux donc on est là on va se
faire envahir c'est ce que vous disent
tous les musulmans on va on va se faire
battre par le ventre des femmes point
donc la guerre a commencé c'est avec le
monde musulman et on va la perdre le
cardinal Lustiger dans un livre que j'ai
lu qui était tout à fait remarquable où
il est intervieué par deux philosophes
volton et l'autre on lui pose la
question vous le l'Église a le temps
long devant elle qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'Europe et le cardinal ltig
il y a 20 ans a dit l'Europe a été perdu
comme nous avons par l'Église comme nous
avons perdu laiminaire pour lui c'était
déjà fait le seul chrétien le seul
continent qui restera chrétien disait-il
c'est l'Amérique latine et l'Amérique du
Sud et l'Amérique du Nord voilà si vous
voulez aller dans des endroits chrétiens
donc si vous voulez on est en guerre et
on est en train de se se baratiner pour
savoir si sera entre la Chine la Russie
les États-Unis alors que le monde
musulman est en guerre contre entre nous
mais qu'est-ce que vous attendez
d'autres écoutez
vraiment monsieur studenikov euh je suis
pas fataliste je pas fataliste dans ce
domaineel parce que écoutez la Russie
nous donne l'exemple de coexistence
absolument pacifique entre les
différentes confession et tout d'abord
entre les musulmans et les chrétiens
parce que les musulmans ils sont
énormément nombreux en Russie 20
millions d'habit absument tatar bachkir
ten j'entends bien mais vous avez vous
avez eu des problèmes avec les ten oui
et que vous avez résolu fortement
écoutez on a euh utilisé les différents
moyens et finalement le problème a été
résolu mais le monde musulman est aussi
euh il n'est pas homogène les pays
musulmans sont différents et je je pense
pas que nous pouvons parler d'un conflit
entre le monde musulman et les
États-Unis ou le reste du monde il y a
le terrorisme euh il y a le radicalisme
islamique et il y a le monde musulman il
faut distinguer les choses le terrorisme
d'État islamique existe mais l'état
islamique c'est une organisation pas de
l'État islamique des États islamiques
l'Arabie saoudite a financé depuis des
des décennies toutes les organisations
terroristes comme le Qatar et on sait
très bien qu'il y a derrière le
terrorisme Hervé je vous donne la parole
oui moi je je je diffère
fondamentalement de de votre position je
suis pas surpris non vous êtes pas
surpris je diffère parce que je crois
que les faits sont plus forts que que
les mots les faits qui
paraisse
important c'est
que dans le monde entier
l'extrémisme
religieux est est
contesté c'est contesté en Europe c'est
contesté en
Asie qui je dirais que
l'extrémisme dogmatique n'est plus de
mise en Union
soviétique donc cet extrémisme là bon
alors il y a 1 milliard de de musulmans
il y a il y aura le monde aura 7
milliards de personnes dans 20 ans 15 %
de la
population et sur ces 15 % probablement
15 % qui sont assez fanatiques et alors
ben vous aviez que 3 % de nazi
hein 3 % de nazis mais mais nous avons
une siété de liberté où les opinions
peuvent s'exprimer ou créer un courant
qui emmène une majorité à à imposer sa
loi est devenu extraordinairement
difficile la société européenne
française américaine et mondiale est en
voie de mutation comme nous ne
soupçonnons pas et cette mutation ne va
pas à mon avis vers un
extrémisme
politico-rigieux qui semblerait dépasser
dans beaucoup de de de de dans dans les
profondeurs des principaux pays mondiaux
je souhaite que vous ayez raison mais
c'est pas ce que je vois dans les
journaux tous les jours ah oui mais moi
je lis pas les journaux
voilà en tout cas c'est la raison pour
laquelle euh nous en Russie nous disons
qu'il faut être beaucoup plus prudent
euh si vous voulez faire quelque chose
dans dans les régions comme moyenne
Orient et Proche Orient il faut pas tout
casser il faut il faut aider à
l'évolution politique de certains pays
parce que il y a des traditions il y a
des les traditions sont telles que la
Syrie était toujours pays beaucoup plus
laïque que l'Arabie Saoudite et le Liban
également avec ses multiples confessions
était beaucoup plus laïque que l'Iran et
en même temps il y a un autre
spécificité de la région aujourd'hui
l'Iran regardez aujourd'hui l'Iran est
un pays plus démocratique que tous les
autres pays de la région parce que
démocratique mais à sa façon oui c'est
état islamique mais il y a la vraie vie
politique il y a la lutte entre les
différentes parties politiques c'est pas
une dictature oui il y a
des des autorités religieuses qui sont
très influ faut mieux être une femme en
Iran qu'en Arabie
Saoudite donc vous voyez combien est
différent cette région combien sont
différents ces pays chaque fois il faut
être vraiment très prudent et il faut
pas essayer apporter la démocratie qui
existe dans les pays occidentaux depuis
des des années et des décennies on peut
pas imposer la démocratie à la façon
occidentale je sais pas à l'Irak ou à la
Syrie peut-être un jour ça va venir mais
pas de telle façon comme le font les
américain je suis d'accord je vais vous
poser une dernière question à tous il a
pas répondu
ou si je peux mon AM ouais parce que
j'ai j'ai des regards un peu un peu
différents on abordé de sujets qui éta F
de Charles sur la partie le conflit
musulman Occident
l'invasion et le premier était la
question sur la trème guerre mondiale
pour répondre au premier moi je suis
moins pessimiste que que ça il y a pas
pour le moment d'État vraiment organisé
qui veut vraiment rentrer en conflit
avec l'Occident après il peut y avoir
des populations en France on a malgré
tout inég qui marche qui marche plutôt
bien maintenant on voit que la situation
actuelle en particulier avec la
Syrie avec les flots de de de de
migrants syriens va poser des gros
problèmes mon avis déjà à l'Union
européenne ça va contribuer mon avis à
son son à son affaiblissement mais on va
voir ce qui va se passer dans certains
pays puisque la tradition en Allemagne
n'est pas aussi une tradition
d'intégration comme elle est comme les
cheîn de mariage mixte par exemple est
très très très différent entre les pays
donc quand il se récupère à presque un
million de de de réfugiés syriens
j'attends de voir comment comment ils
vont comment ils vont les traiter mais
ceci étant comme pour le moment cux qui
bénéficient économiquement de l'euro et
de la construction européenne et Ben qui
s'occupe des migrants aussi quiessayie
pas de les refiler aux autres pays parce
que comme ça ville commenah ville commen
ville
commen premier point mais bon quoi qu'il
en soit c'est c'est un sujet
effectivement qui est souvent dans les
têtes on va dire peut-être qu'on sera
d'accord làdessus que c'est quandme un
sujet plutôt de moyen terme pour qu'il a
un moyen terme faut qu'il a un court
terme comme dirait comme dirait la
paliss et là moi j'ai envie de citer
Albert Einstein qui disait je ne connais
pas les armes de la trème Guerre
mondiale pour la 4 ce sera des caillou
ça me semble encore très optimiste je
pense pas qu'il y aura une 4e guerre
mondiale si si s'il y a une 3ème vu les
dégâts que peuvent causer des des
conflits des conflits
nucléaires vous disz tout à l'heure on
veut pas en parler Mo je pense qu'il
faut en parler quand même en tout cas
quand on regarde ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis et c'est d'ailleurs très
inquiétant ils en parlent vous regardez
dans les commissions militaires des
comités de la défense euxière menace
c'est la Russie ou Russie toute façon on
gratte un peu que la Chine n'est pas
bien loin et là ce qui est assez
fascinant mais je pense qu'il doit être
assez enfin on a évoqué le su tout à
l'heure pourquoi non parce qu'il y a pas
de problème avec la Russie ça n'est plus
au tempants duurss plus enin quand on
regarde la Russie est un pays qui est
globalement démocratique a sans doute
des choses à redire mais enfin bon par
rapport à pas mal d'autres pays de la
planète c'est déjà c'est déjà quand même
pas si mal que ça il envahit personne
personne dans son entourage c'est pas
quand compar la Russie avec les
États-Unis enfin on voit s' un pays qui
déstabilise le monde il me semble pas
que ce soit la Russie donc on pourrait
dire bon son plus communistes je pense
j'ai pas senti des poussés communistes
moi chez chez Poutine et pourtant on a
un vent de folie parce que enfin on est
sur niveau psychiatrique quand on
regarde disait la presse aujourd'hui
enfin on a une russophobie enfin qui
vaut le Bosch de 1914 hein sachant qu'il
nous fait rien la position géopolitique
de la Russie a été exprimée très bien
par par Poutine en 2007 qui était en
gros nous ce qu'on aimerait bien si ça
vous dérange pas n être amis avec
l'Europe hein voilà la la vision russe
hein je pense pas la trahir c'est ce
qu'il vouleit en disant on a les mêmes
intérêts euh restez amis avec les
États-Unis mais enfin soyez aussi amis
avec nous trouvons un monde équilibré
voilà la vision russe ce qu'on leura
fait ce qu'on leura craché dessus bon
c'est c'est pas très très cool et puis
qu'on le fait souvent et pour des
raisons délirantes que ce soit l'Ukraine
que ce soit sur des ça sur des sujets
même symboliques hein l'histoire des
Mistral ENF c'est c'est délirant le vend
pas un bateau parce que c'est un porte
hélicoptère le disant ça se trouve vous
allez l'utiliser pour envillir l'Ukraine
ils ont 3000 km de frontière mais on
veut pas le vendre un bateau pour
transporter des enfin c'est enfin c'est
comme si si la Russie n vend pas un
bateau des fois qu'on l'utilise pour
envahir l'Allemagne enfin c'est c'est
stupide donc je sais pas comment les
Russes comprennent ça mais mais mais en
tout cas c'est assez incompréhensible
quand on le regarde et pourtant on voit
qu'on a une presse qui s'acharne qui
s'acharne là-dessus pour faire monter
des tensions
et qui sont qui sont extrêmement
déstabilisantes et et on a cette vision
aux États-Unis que je trouve de plus en
plus inquiétante qui une vision
messianique alors ils l'ont toujours eu
la vision la destinée manifeste quand on
regarde comme ils se sont construits
parce qu'au début
c'était un petit lot de de de
colonisation sur la côte Est américaine
et on voit qu'ils ont une vision disant
faut qu'on enisse tout le continent
c'est à nous c'est on va apporter la
liberté sur ce continent alors bon pour
les Indiens c'est loupé hein ça pas été
une grande liberté mais ils ont eu le
continent puis après on voit qu'ils ont
voulu envoyir le Canada puis on voit
qu'ils ont voulu piquer le Mexique puis
fin ils ont fait le leur zone puis après
on voit que l'étape suivante a été tiens
maintenant on va apporter la démocratie
sur la planète al évidemment ils ont
jouer un rôle stabilisateur dans la
guerre froide mais là il y a plus
d'ennemis donc on aura pu dire bon bah
va se calmer maintenant on va dissoudre
l' temp on va revenir à des choses
équilibré pas du tout c'est maintenant
en fait il y a plus d'ennemis alors
après le terrorisme tiens ça a servi un
certain temps puis là on voit que
maintenant malgré tout le terrorisme ça
marche moins bien quoi comme ennemi
fédérateur c'est pas terrible on voit
que il cherche un nouvel ennemiment la
Russie bon c'est pas de bol c'est
retombé sur vous mais on gratte un peu
on voit que la Chine sera pas loin
derrière de toute façon c'est le coup
d'après et ça c'est assez c'est assz
inquiétant parce qu'il y a pas de raison
objective comme des pays la Chine ou la
Russie qui sont pas interventionnistes
qui menacent pas les États-Unis il y a
tout ce qu'il faut pour vivre en paix on
voit qu'il y a une stratégie de la
tension permanente et sur quelque chose
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas réaliste qui
se
construit ce qu'on appelle maintenant
des narratives donc cette espèce de de
de fiction on croit donc par exemple il
y a un dictateur sur la planète c'est
Poutine vous regardez enfin c'est du
délire mais c'est pas grave c'est c'est
ça rentre dans les esprits on voit que
ça saautoalimente par tout toute une
gestion médiatique des pseudo experts
qui sont d'ailleurs très proche des
États-Unis puis finissent par croire à
leur discours et puis le politique il
est paralysé parce que tout d'un coup
quand la population se met à vomir
Poutine bah on peut plus être sympa avec
Poutine quand on est dirigeant politique
et donc ça c'est des stratégies de
tension qui sont complètement
irrationnelles et qui sont très
inquiétantes dans la diplomatie
occidentale et je pense que ce va-être
très difficile dans une vision russe ou
chinoise de comprendre ce qui se passe
en disant mais vous êtes cinglé oui on
est cinglé
oui parce que les États-Unis ont cette
visionl on l'a vu on va porter la
démocratie en Irak bon après cette
expérience on aurait pu dire ils vont
arrêter quoi ils vont quitter la zone
excusez-nous rendre les clés aux autres
et puis non non il continuent et là
maintenant ils sont en train de renvoyer
des troupes en en Syrie après avoir fait
la bombarder donc donc on voit qu'il y a
pas de limite et on voit qu'ils ont en
tête et je répète regardez il y a eu ça
le mois dernier dans des discours enfin
en tout cas dans des travaux de
commission politique et sénatorial de la
Défense américaine une vision oui oui la
guerre est possible et si ça se trouve
ce sera dans quelques années c'est pas
dans quelques décennies Hervé
il y a un besoin
américain d'avoir un un ennemi à d'avoir
une
opposition de se distinguer bon
alors ils sont retombés sur la Russie
alors qu'il est évident que l'Europe a
besoin d'une relation sereine positive
et en développement économique et en
lutte contre le terrorisme avec la
Russie très clairement que les Russes
jouent le rôle avec l'Europe bien et que
cette passion
américaine d'exister en ayant un
adversaire total il y a encore des
restes de cela et revenant des
États-Unis j'ai constaté qu'il y avait
des gens de 40 45 ans qui euh tenait le
même discours que j'avais connu il y a
50 ans hein euh quand j'y avais été pour
d'autres raisons donc il y a une
attitude un préjugé américain qui a
besoin d'un adversaire et bien nous
devons euh je dirais avoir un peu
d'humour les laisser les Américains
veulent ça très bien nous respectons et
nousis nous tissons un réseau avec la
Russie et avec cette région plus dense
plus constructif plus économique plus
culturel hein on a quand même énormément
à retirer de la culture russe et et
vice-versa donc moi je ne m'en inquiète
pas je crois qu'il faut il y a des gens
qui ont des préjugés et ben il faut le
leur laisser voilà
Charles je vais vous poser à tous une
dernière question la question c'est
laisser qu'est-ce que vous avez comme
conseil à laisser aux jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer sur
Internet c'est-à-dire que votre parole
arrivera peut-être dans l'ordinateur
d'un ado qui s'intéresserait à des
sujets un peu harides donc à chacun vous
aurez à répondre de cette question à
répondre à cette question laissz un
conseil aux jeunes générations vous avez
une minute ne pas avoir peur ne pas
avoir peur le monde actuel est
extraordinairement intéressant jamais
l'espace de liberté individu n'a été
aussi fort il y a des tentatives faites
par les États pour continuer à nous
mettre en esclavage mais grâce à Dieu
grâce à la technologie ne pas avoir peur
et penser aux structures horizontales
c'est-à-dire rester léger ne pas se
coller dans des grandes structures
pyramidales qui vont toutes s'écrouler
il faut rester léger rester souple et
être prêt à bouger s'il les jeune il
faut être prêt à bouger quand je suis
arrivé à Hong Kong il y avait 2000
français en 19 18 aujourd'hui il y en a
25000 donc si vous voulez la quasi
totalité des gens compétents en France
travaillent aujourd'hui à Londres à New
York ou à Hong Kong ou n'importe où dès
que la France cessera de faire des
bêtises faudra revenir monsieur le
ministre conseiller euh moi je
proposerais de réfléchir et d'analyser
de ne pas croire euh à n'importe quel
euh mass médiia tout simplement comparer
euh lire grâce à l'Internet il y a
vraiment je me souviens de mes années
d'étudiant et
d'écolers c'est difficile à imaginer
maintenant de ne pas avoir l'accès à
l'Internet donc maintenant tout est
possible analyser les différentes
sources d'information réfléchissz
euh donc voilà c'est ce que je peux
proposer et créer votre propre vision en
se basant sur différentes sources
d'information ne prenez pas le fait
qui a été proposé par quelqu'un essayez
de de décider essayer de de de créer
votre propre vision des choses sans
intermédiaire prenez les différentes
sources d'information et
réfléchissez
d'accord moi je
prendrais la formule de Lénine apprendre
apprendre pour agir et comprendre
apprendre apprendre et encore une fois
apprendre voilà comment on le dit en
russe
Olivier
beruet il existe de très beaux textes de
1912 1913 puisqueà cette épo là il y
avait déjà une première
mondialisation et les gens expliquaient
qu'il auraient plus jamais de conflit
parce que les intérêts étaient croisés
qu'il fallait pas s'inquiéter que les
guerres c'était du passé on voit très
bien que la folie humaine
malheureusement ne remplit pas des des
critères des critères logiques donc pour
coup le jeune je dirais pour le coup toi
oui a peur parce qu'en tout cas c'est
comme dans l'idée si tu veux veut la
paix prépare la guerre enfin en tout cas
craint toujours le pire pour éviter
qu'il qu'il
n'arrive pour ça pour B direussi sur ce
que vous disiez moi je
citerai grand philosophe Bertrand
Russell qui disait ne soyez jamais sûr
de rien c'est déjà une base
intéressante de de de de de critères en
tout cas voilà creusez les choses n'ayez
pas confiance dans les médias et
battez-vous résistez parce que ce sera
le prochain combat dites grâce aux
technologies on est plus libre je pense
que bientôt on sera moins libre grâce
nouvell techn et je pense que les États
contrebalanceront rapidement
malheureusement résister parce que c'est
ce sera le prochain
combat à mon avis voilà ce que ce que je
dirais en en général n'ayez pas peur
c'éta jean-pul i oui oui oui je sais
messieurs je vous remercie cette
interview est maintenant terminée merci
beaucoup
[Musique]